This episode is brought to you by Defender. With the towing capacity of 3,500 kilograms and a waiting depth of 900 millimeters, the Defender 110 pushes what's possible. Learn more at landrover.ca. It's Rona Week, now until Wednesday. You hear that? That's the sound of your summer getting a second life. It's the sound of a Rona pressure washer at only 99.
本集由 Defender 赞助播出。凭借 3,500 公斤的拖曳能力和 900 毫米的涉水深度，Defender 110 不断突破潜能的极限。请登录 landrover.ca 了解更多信息。现在到星期三是 Rona 周。你听到了吗？那是你的夏天重获新生的声音。那是 Rona 高压清洗机仅售 99 的声音。
It's the sound of a clean patio, a sparkling truck, clear gutters, and a shiny driveway. Build it right, build it Rona. Conditions apply, details in store, and more offers at rona.ca. Okay, shut it off, fellas. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office. lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with
这是庭院洁净、卡车闪亮、排水沟畅通、车道发亮的声音。精工细作，就选 Rona。受条款约束，详情请见店内，更多优惠请访问 rona.ca.好了，伙计们，关掉它。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是好朋友。现在，我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将深入探讨
exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello, everyone. Hi there. Today on Office Lady 6.0, Michael Scott's favorite concierge joins us. That's right, it's Wendy McClendon Covey, and she's in the studio with us. Oh, I loved this interview. Wendy is so hilarious. Well, back when we were breaking down business trip in season five, Wendy sent us some audio clips about her time on the show as concierge Marie. They were just fantastic. But today, we got to have her in studio with us, and she is exactly as fun and funny as you imagine.
独家采访、幕后细节以及大量 BFF（死党）故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0 版。大家好。大家好。今天在《办公室女士》6.0 版中，迈克尔·斯科特最喜欢的礼宾员加入了我们。没错，就是温迪·麦克伦东-科维，她和我们一起在录音室里。哦，我太喜欢这次采访了。温迪太搞笑了。回想我们在第五季中拆解《出差》那一集时，温迪给我们发送了一些音频剪辑，讲述了她在节目中饰演礼宾员玛丽的时光。它们真是太棒了。但今天，我们把她请到了录音室里，她和你想想的一样有趣、好笑。
And you guys, our breakdown of business trip is such a fun episode. So if you haven't heard it, it's on our website, OfficeLadies.com. Hot tip at any point. If you ever want to go back and listen to an episode, they're all on our website. And Wendy is just fantastic in business trip, but she's just crazy talented in every regard. Yeah. You might recognize her from her role as Beverly. Over 10 seasons on the Goldbergs, she was nominated for two Critics Choice Awards, or maybe you know her as Deputy Clementine Johnson from Reno 911, the animated show Big City Greens, and she was nominated. She worked with our fellow office alums, Paul Figue and Ellie Kemper on Bridesmaids.
大家注意了，我们对《出差》的拆解是一集非常有趣的节目。所以如果你没听过，可以在我们的网站 OfficeLadies.com 上收听。温馨提示，在任何时候，如果你想回听某一集，它们都在我们的网站上。温迪在《出差》中的表现简直太棒了，而且她在各方面都才华横溢。对。你可能认得出她在《戈德堡一家》中饰演了 10 个季度的贝弗利角色，她因此获得了两个评论家选择奖提名；或者你认识她在《雷诺 911》中饰演的副警长克莱门廷·约翰逊、动画片《大城小绿》，并且她还获得了提名。她曾与我们的办公室老校友保罗·费格和埃莉·肯珀合作过《伴娘》。
That's right. She was cousin Rita. So funny. And now you can catch her on another hit television show with another member of our office family, writer-producer, Justin Spitzer. She plays hospital administrator Joyce in St. Dennis Medical on NBC. And it's so good, you guys. It's so good.
没错。她扮演表姐丽塔。太搞笑了。现在你可以在另一部热门电视剧中看到她，该剧由我们办公室家族的另一位成员、编剧兼制片人贾斯汀·斯皮策创作。她在 NBC 的《圣丹尼斯医疗》中饰演医院管理员乔伊斯。真的太棒了，伙计们。真的太棒了。
The cast is phenomenal. The writing is hilarious. We're watching it and loving it. Yes, I love Alison Tolman. She plays sort of the head nurse. It's a beautiful show. It really is. It's so funny, but then it also really packs a punch.
演员阵容非常豪华。剧本太搞笑了。我们在看，而且非常喜欢。是的，我喜欢艾莉森·托尔曼。她饰演某种护士长。这是一部精美的剧集。真的。它不仅非常搞笑，而且非常有感染力。
If you're not watching it, I highly, highly recommend. Yes. You know, I met Allison one time, and she's so nice. We're such fans of hers, lady. I hope we get a chance to talk to her someday. I am angling to be on St. Dennis Medical. Same. In fact, you guys, Jen and I are both pitching ourselves for different roles.
如果你没看的话，我强烈、强烈推荐。是的。你知道，我有一次遇到过艾莉森，她人非常好。我们非常崇拜她，女士们。我希望有一天我们能有机会和她聊聊。我正摩拳擦掌想加入《圣丹尼斯医疗》。我也是。事实上，伙计们，珍和我都在为不同的角色推销自己。
Before we go to break, I thought we should have a lot of little refresher about concierge Marie's scenes. So you guys remember, Michael is really down because Holly was transferred. So David Wallace sends him and Oscar and Andy to Winnipeg to close a sale. And clearly, this is Michael's first time ever meeting a concierge. And he is in his own words, blown away. Let's hear it. Where's the concierge? Yes. Wallace said there would be one of those? Mm, bingo. Follow one bro, sir.
在我们进入广告休息之前，我想我们应该回顾一下礼宾员玛丽的场景。所以大家还记得，迈克尔因为霍莉被调走而非常沮丧。于是大卫·华莱士派他和奥斯卡以及安迪去温尼伯谈成一笔交易。显然，这是迈克尔生平第一次见到礼宾员。用他自己的话说，他被震撼到了。我们听听看。礼宾员在哪里？是的。华莱士说会有这样的人？唔，太棒了。跟着走，老兄，先生。
Wow. What about a nice sushi place? Maybe a place with a view? Oh. Matsuki. That's a good one. You may walk there if you wish, or you may take the number 17 bus
哇。那不错的寿司店怎么样？也许是一个带风景的地方？哦。松树。那个不错。如果你愿意，可以步行去，或者你可以坐 17 路公交车
until nine o'clock. Other than that, you can take the taxi and the number is right there. Wow. Wow. I'm blown away by this. I um this is great thank you one final question where might you find yourself on a Winnipeg night like tonight
直到九点钟。除此之外，你可以坐出租车，号码就在那里。哇。哇。我被这个震撼到了。我，嗯，这太棒了，谢谢。最后一个问题，今晚这样的温尼伯之夜，你会在哪里度过呢？
oh the huntsman is good the huntsman down here the financial district Michael is so easily impressed it's so cute I know he's enamored by all of it like the travel the hotel the concierge and the way when is playing the concierge, it's just like, it's so rote. Like, how many times has she recommended these restaurants? And got out the map and dropped about the bus. Yes. Well, as the night goes on, they have drinks, and Michael continues to be very impressed.
哦，亨茨曼不错，这里的亨茨曼，金融区。迈克尔太容易被打动了，太可爱了。我知道，他被这一切迷住了，比如旅行、酒店、礼宾员，还有温迪扮演礼宾员的方式，简直太套路了。比如，她推荐这些餐厅多少次了？还拿出了地图，顺便提到了公交车。是的。嗯，随着夜幕降临，他们喝了酒，迈克尔仍然非常兴奋。
How about this one? It's Christmas Eve, and everything is closed, and you need to get some dry cleaning done. 12 o'clock, midnight. Where do you go? What do you do? What do you do? Come on. What do you do? Astro cleaners on St. James Place is the only place that is open on that day.
这个怎么样？平安夜，所有店铺都关门了，你需要干洗一些衣服。12 点，午夜。你去哪儿？你做什么？你做什么？快点。你做什么？圣詹姆斯广场的 Astro 清洁店是那天唯一开门的地方。
Unbelievable. Unbelievable. Michael is so turned on by her knowledge. Unbelievable. She knows where the dry cleaners are. At any point of any day, she knows where you can go. I love this episode. I love the storyline so much. And I loved our conversation with Wendy. She's a really special person, and she shared a lot. And I can't wait for everyone to hear it.
难以置信。难以置信。迈克尔被她的知识深深迷住了。难以置信。她知道干洗店在哪里。在任何一天的任何时间，她都知道你可以去哪里。我太喜欢这一集了。我太喜欢这个故事线了。我也非常喜欢我们与温迪的对话。她是一个非常特别的人，她分享了很多。我迫不及待地想让大家听到。
Same lady. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, Wendy is in the studio. This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal? Do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, You know, what helps you get through the day?
我也是，女士。好吧，我们休息一下。回来后，温迪就在录音室里。这是一则由 BetterHelp 提供的广告。你知道，现在感觉几乎每件事都有各种建议。就像，你写日记吗？你做，我不知道，排毒、冷水浴，或者，你知道，你知道是什么帮你度过这一天吗？
What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through better help. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on...
是什么帮你度过充满压力的时刻？嗯。对我来说，是把事情说出来。嗯。关于心理健康和健康的信息可能会严重过载，如今要想知道什么是真理、该采取什么行动可能会是一场挣扎。所以你可以考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，通过 BetterHelp 与真人治疗师交谈。它在应用商店的评分为 4.9 分（满分 5 分），基于...
over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Hi, I'm PJ Vote, and I want to tell you about my podcast search engine. We try to make sense of the world. One question at a time. No question too big, no question too small. We will even answer your questions if you send them in.
超过 170 万客户评价。作为全球最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以提供拥有各种不同专业知识的心理健康专家的帮助。通过 BetterHelp 把话说出来。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 office ladies 首次订购可享 90% 折扣。这就是 BetterHelp，H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。嗨，我是 P·J·沃特，我想向你介绍我的播客搜索引擎。我们试着理解这个世界。一次解决一个问题。没有太大的问题，也没有太小的问题。如果你把问题发给我们，我们甚至会回答你的问题。
Stuff like, what happens when a cemetery goes out of business? What should we do about teens using AI to do their homework? Who buys luggage at the airport luggage store? Follow and listen to Search Engine, in partnership with Odyssey, wherever you get your podcasts. Tim's new scrambled egg loaded croissant, or is it croissant? No matter how you say it, start your day with fresh, Crack scrambled eggs loaded on a buttery, flaky croissant.
比如，当一个公墓倒闭时会发生什么？对于青少年使用人工智能做作业，我们该怎么办？谁会在机场行李店买行李箱？在您获取播客的任何地方关注并收听由 Odyssey 合作推出的《搜索引擎》。蒂姆全新的炒蛋至尊牛角包，还是说牛角包？无论你怎么说，用松软酥脆的牛角包上满满的现打炒蛋，开启你的美好一天。
Try it with maple brown butter today at Timms at participating restaurants in Canada for limited time. Woo-hoo! Wendy! You guys! What's up? Oh, my head's going to explode with happiness. Just pure joy. Yeah.
今天就在加拿大的蒂姆参与门店限时尝试枫糖红糖黄油口味。呜呼！温迪！大家！怎么了？哦，我的头要幸福得爆炸了。纯粹的快乐。对。
I've been so looking forward to this. I have been looking forward to it as well. And now it's happening and I can't believe I'm looking at you. I know. Lady. Ladies are much emotion. When you got here, we were reflecting on the last time we saw one another in person because you were on the office, but we were not in your scenes.
我一直非常期待这一刻。我也一直很期待。现在它发生了，我简直不敢相信我正在看着你。我懂的。女士。女士们，太多的情绪了。你一到这里，我们就回想起我们上次亲自见面的时候，因为你曾出演过《办公室》，但我们不在你的场景里。
Right. And so you remembered the last time we saw each other. Will you share? It was called the Fur Ball. And it was like a kitty rescue fundraiser. Yeah. And you were one of the hosts, I believe. Yes.
没错。所以你还记得我们上次见面的情景。你愿意分享一下吗？它叫“毛球派对”。就像是一个小猫救援筹款活动。是的。而且你似乎是主持人之一。是的。
I worked with kitten rescue who puts on that fundraiser. for years. And that's one of the many reasons why I love you guys is because you care about the little creatures. Yes, and so do you. Because if you follow you on Instagram, Wendy, you know, your love of critters. I'm always feeding something. And that giant hawk, what was that thing? They are all around our neighborhood. And the carnage that happens in our flower beds is not pretty. I know. We were doing an edit session recently. And out my window, we were, remember Cassie, Angela, we were on Zoom? And all of a sudden it was like a bird exploded in front of my window.
我多年来一直与举办该筹款活动的小猫救援组织合作。这也是我喜欢你们的众多原因之一，因为你们关心小动物。是的，你也是。因为如果你在 Instagram 上关注你，温迪，你就会知道你对小动物的爱。我总是在喂养什么东西。还有那只巨大的鹰，那是什么东西？它们在我们的社区到处都是。花坛里发生的大屠杀可不好看。我知道。我们最近在做剪辑。从我的窗户看出去，我们当时正在进行，安吉拉，还记得吗，我们在 Zoom 上？突然之间，就像一只鸟在我的窗户前爆炸了。
And I think it's because a big, like, hawk came down. I bombed it. That's happened in my backyard. Just like confetti of feathers. Oh, God. It was very startling. And there's nothing you can do. Nothing.
我想这是因为一只大鹰俯冲下来。它把它炸毁了。这在我的后院发生过。就像羽毛做成的五彩纸屑。哦，天哪。这太吓人了。你无能为力。无能为力。
That was just Mother Nature, sorting some stuff out. But it's a little brutal to watch. Yeah. I didn't know we were going to start. Hi, everybody. I was about to tell a story about when I watched a squirrel eat a hummingbird and then I didn't realize squirrels eat hummingbirds. And then I decided not to tell it. And now I'm saying it out loud.
那只是大自然母亲在解决一些事情。但看着确实有点残酷。是的。我不知道我们要开始。大家好。我正要讲一个故事，讲我看到一只松鼠吃了一只蜂鸟，然后我才意识到松鼠会吃蜂鸟。然后我决定不讲了。现在我大声说出来了。
Well, listen, nature is disgusting. And I prefer it when nature stays outside. Keep it outside. Yeah. Do your thing outside. Oh, keep it outside. But furball is a great, great event. Yeah.
听着，大自然太恶心了。我更喜欢大自然呆在户外的时候。把它留在户外。是的。在外面做你该做的事。哦，把它留在户外。不过毛球派对是一个非常非常棒的活动。是的。
And we were all there. I still have a tea. pot I bid on at that auction. Really? And it's a cat. And the head comes off and then you put it on and the water comes out its mouth. So he's like, meo. Oh, my goodness.
我们都在那儿。我到现在还有一个在那个拍卖会上竞拍的茶壶。真的吗？它是一个猫咪形状的。头可以拿下来，然后你把它装上，水就会从它的嘴里流出来。所以它就像在说：喵。哦，天哪。
It's so adorable. I hope you use it all the time. Only for my friends when they come over. So, Wendy, when you come over, get ready. I'll remember that you said. Wendy, we know that you sent in some audio clips when we broke down your episode business trip, but we're just so excited to have you in studio. Will you tell us again the story of how you got your job on the office? Yes, yes. So it was, it was kind of crazy. I had just been fired off
太可爱了。我希望你一直都在用它。只在我的朋友过来的时候用。所以，温迪，你过来的时候，准备好吧。我会记住你说的。温迪，我们知道当我们拆解你的那一集《出差》时，你寄来了一些音频剪辑，但我们非常高兴能邀请你来到录音室。你能再给我们讲讲你是如何得到《办公室》这份工作的吗？好的，好的。所以，当时，这有点疯狂。我刚刚被解雇了
a movie that I had auditioned, I had done all these things, they flew me out to Michigan. I was there one night, got in the passenger van to go to set, and the money guy decided I was not pretty enough to do the role. So I was put on a plane crying to go right back to L.A. So wait, you are in the van. You get to set and they say, yeah, I'm sorry, that's it. Don't go to your dressing room. Holy crap. That is so brutal. It was pretty brutal. And yet a blessing, because that movie went nowhere. Okay. And I would have had to be in Michigan for seven weeks waiting to film for only five days. Oh, of five intermittent days.
我试镜过的一部电影，我做了所有这些事情，他们把我飞到密歇根州。我在那里呆了一晚，上了去片场的客货车，然后金钱大佬决定我长得不够漂亮，不适合这个角色。于是我哭着坐上飞机直接回洛杉矶了。等等，你在面包车里。你到了片场，他们说，是的，对不起，就是这样。不要去你的化妆室。天哪。这太残酷了。确实挺残酷的。不过这也是因祸得福，因为那部电影没拍成。好吧。我本得在密歇根呆七周，却只能拍五天。哦，断断续续的五天。
Oh, no. Come on. So that's fine. That's how the universe works. Right. You know, sometimes you're in the wrong place and something horrible has to happen to get you in the right place. So when I land in L.A., I look at my phone and my phone's blowing up because I had gotten an offer to do the office the next day. So thank God I got fired, right?
哦，不。拜托。没关系。这就是宇宙的运作方式。没错。你知道，有时候你在错误的地方，必须发生一些可怕的事情才能让你去到正确的地方。所以当我降落在洛杉矶时，我看着手机，我的手机快炸了，因为我收到了第二天去拍《办公室》的邀约。所以谢天谢地我被解雇了，对吧？
Because nobody saw that movie, but everybody saw this. Okay. Can you say the movie? You don't have, you know what, we're going to do a special podcast called Office Ladies, Burn It to the Ground, when we're in our late 60s. Yes. And you can come back. Yes. And then I'll name names. Definitely. Because we have some stories to tell, but we're putting them in our pocket for a few years. That's smart. Yeah. That's very smart. When we're really old and gives zero Fs. Yeah. We're going to burn it down. Okay. I'll like that. I'll like that. I'll bring the tequila for that episode.
因为没有人看过那部电影，但所有人都看过这个。好吧。你能说出那部电影的名字吗？你不用，你知道吗，当我们六十多岁的时候，我们要做一个特别的播客，叫做《办公室女士：把它夷为平地》。是的。你可以回来。是的。然后我会点名。肯定的。因为我们有一些故事要讲，但我们要把它们揣在口袋里几年。这很聪明。是的。这非常聪明。当我们真的老了，毫不在乎的时候。是的。我们要把它烧成灰烬。好吧。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。我会为那一集带龙舌兰酒的。
Okay. So anyway, I, I, uh, my whole thing was with Steve Correll. And we were in Winnipeg. So I didn't get to meet you guys, which was stinky. So we're filming at a hotel somewhere in L.A. Yeah, in downtown L.A. Kate Flannery drove by and said hello. So that was cute. Oh, that's so nice.
好吧。总之，我，我，呃，我的全部事情都是和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在一起的。我们在温尼伯。所以我没能见到你们，这太糟糕了。所以我们在洛杉矶某处的酒店拍摄。是的，在洛杉矶市中心。凯特·弗兰内里开车路过并打了招呼。所以这很可爱。哦，太棒了。
And then, okay, so it was on a Friday. The weekend goes on. Monday I come back. And during lunch, I'm in my trailer eating. I get a call that I'm not going to be on. anymore. Wait, what? So I am sobbing in my trailer.
然后，好吧，那是星期五。周末过去了。星期一我回来了。午饭期间，我正在我的拖车里吃饭。我接到电话说我不再出演了。等等，什么？所以我坐在拖车里号啕大哭。
Yes. Was on the set of the office? Yeah. Yeah. So I was like, I mean, I was like, well, now I'm going to get fired from this job because I can't collect myself. It was terrible. But the experience was so fun.
是的。是在《办公室》的片场吗？对。对。所以我想，我的意思是，我想，好吧，现在我要被这份工作解雇了，因为我无法控制自己。太可怕了。但这段经历太有趣了。
And Steve Correll is a doll. I love the way the episode turned out. I loved, like, I'm in my full uniform, but no shit. shoes on, kicking him at, like, what did we do in there? Because you've dressed already. Yeah, I got dressed in a hurry to throw his shoes out the door. Was I just on a break and had to go back down to my desk? I don't know.
而且史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是个宝贝。我很喜欢这一集的成品，我喜欢，比如，我穿着全套制服，但是没穿鞋子，踢他，像，我们在里面做了什么？因为你已经穿好衣服了。对，我匆忙穿好衣服把他的鞋子扔出门外。我是刚好在休息，然后得回我的办公桌吗？我不知道。
We want to know where that hotel room came from. I guess you set that up. Yeah. Concierge Marie would have access. Would have access. You didn't go to his room. No, it was my, like, little lair or something. Yeah.
我们想知道那个酒店房间是哪里来的。我猜那是你安排的。对。礼宾员玛丽会有权限的。会有权限的。你没有去他的房间。不，那是我的小窝之类的地方。对。
You know how, like, though, at hotels, they have that room where if you have a layover, and you're like, hey, can I just go shower somewhere and there's that room? There is. Yeah. I don't know about the layover room. I've never heard this. Yeah. I did this once. I had a layover and I got a room like just for a few hours so I could shower. Yes, you can do this. What hotel chain was it? Well, it was right off the airport. Oh, sure, sure, sure.
你知道，就像酒店里那样，他们有那种房间，如果你转机停留，然后你会说，嘿，我可以在哪里洗个澡，然后有那个房间吗？有的。是的。我不知道转机房间这回事。我从来没听说过。是的。我曾经这样做过。我转机停留，然后开了一个房间，只待了几个小时，这样我就可以洗个澡。是的，你可以这样做。那是哪个连锁酒店？哦，就在机场旁边。哦，当然，当然，当然。
But I used to work at a hotel as well. And everybody knows like, okay, let me look up. Oh, there's a room on the corner that nobody's in. if you want to go have a hookup, and the employees would do this. Oh, disgusting, but yes, they would do that. That's some good hospitality gossip. Very unsavory. What did you do in the hotel business? I was a secretary back when they called them secretaries, and then I became like a salesperson for corporate sales.
不过我也曾在酒店工作过。每个人都知道，好吧，让我查一下。哦，拐角处有一个没人住的房间。如果你想去约会，员工们就会这么做。哦，太恶心了，不过是的，他们会这么做。这是一些精彩的酒店八卦。非常不雅。你在酒店行业做什么？我曾经是一名秘书，当时人们称他们为秘书，然后我成了企业销售的销售人员。
I tried to get people to come and stay in our shittity little hotel. I'm sorry, can I swear? You can't. Okay. So this was, I worked at a place near Disneyland. It was like the third worst Ramada in Anaheim. And it was just far enough. It was literally across train tracks from the rest of where everyone goes to stay.
我试图让人来我们那个破烂的小酒店住宿。抱歉，我可以骂人吗？你不能。好吧。所以这个，我在迪士尼乐园附近的一个地方工作。它就像阿纳姆第三差的华美达酒店。而且它离得很远。它 literally 穿过了铁轨，与其他人去住的地方隔离开来。
Yeah, where tourist Anaheim turns into industrial Anaheim. Okay. So this was basically a trucker hotel, but we were trying to make it into a destination property. So we put in, it was terrible. How do you put a bow on that? I mean, we put a waterfall in the front. Hey. You know, to really offset the fact that we didn't have hallways, just like outside corridors, you know, next to the rock-breaking factory or like the gravel factory.
是的，旅游景点的阿纳姆变成工业区的阿纳姆的地方。好吧。所以这基本上是一家卡车司机酒店，但我们正试图把它变成一个目的地酒店。所以我们投入了，太糟糕了。你怎么能在那种地方粉饰呢？我的意思是，我们在前面装了一个喷泉。嘿。你知道，为了真正掩盖我们没有走廊的事实，只有外面的走廊，你知道的，挨着碎石厂或者砾石厂。
Yeah, it was horrible. But boy, did we try. I read, though, that when you were doing that, you would then drive 35 miles to L.A. to take classes at the groundlings. Yep. Yep. Wow. Yeah. And I'm still too stubborn to leave that area. So I'm down in Long Beach. I've never left. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my goodness. You drove all the way here from Long Beach? That's because I'm too stubborn to leave. My parents are nearby. My mother-in-law is nearby. Everybody's nearby. I'm not leaving. Yeah. But, yes, could I make it more difficult?
是的，太可怕了。但天哪，我们真努力。不过我读到过，当你做那个工作时，你会开车 35 英里去洛杉矶去 Groundlings（演员工会剧团）上课。没错。没错。哇。是的。而且我还是太顽固了，不肯离开那个地区。所以我住在长滩。我从来没离开过。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。你从长滩一路开车到这里来？那是因为我太顽固了，不想离开。我父母在附近。我婆婆在附近。大家都在附近。我才不走呢。是的，不过，对，我能不能把它弄得更难一点？
I guess I could if I, like, moved to San Diego, but yeah, it's a hall. Listen, if my family lived somewhere here, I'd be where they are. Yeah. But they're just all the way in Texas, and so I can't. You can't. I get that. Oh, well, thank you so much for driving so far. Of course, of us today.
我想如果我搬到圣迭戈的话可能会吧，不过是的，挺远的。听着，如果我的家人住在这里的某个地方，我就会去他们住的地方。是的。但他们全都在德克萨斯，所以我不能。你不能。我懂的。哦，好吧，非常感谢你开这么远的车。当然，今天我们。
I have no idea. No, I'm honored. Are you kidding? But, wow. So you were doing that drive to go take classes at the groundlings. And sometimes we would get so nervous that we would just drive right past and go home. Stop it. Yeah.
我不知道。不，我很荣幸。你在开玩笑吗？但是，哇。所以你当时开车去 Groundlings 上课。有时我们会紧张得直接开过去然后回家。别这样。是的。
You'd make it all the way to Melrose and just say, I can't. I can't get out. Yeah. I'm too nervous. Yeah. I took classes there. What year were you there, Wendy? I started in 97 and you know how long it used to take.
你一路开到梅尔罗斯，然后就说，我不行。我出不去了。是的。我太紧张了。是的。我在那儿上过课。温迪，你是什么时候在那里的？我从 97 年开始，你知道以前要花多长时间。
It would take like two years because the waiting list was so long. Yeah. I think we bounced around around the same time. What is your kind of like actory? backstory, Wendy, where are you from? And how did you get here? Are you from Long Beach originally? Yeah, that's the only place I've ever lived. I never went away to school. I'm very boring. You're born and raised Long Beach. Long Beach. Yeah. When did you get like the acting bug or the comedy bug? Very early in life, but I didn't start really pursuing it in earnest until I got married
大概要花两年时间，因为等待名单太长了。是的。我想我们差不多在同一时间四处游荡。温迪，你的演艺背景是什么？你是哪里人？你是怎么来到这里的？你原本就是长滩人吗？是的，那是这辈子我唯一住过的地方。我从来没有离开去外地学校。我很无聊。你是在长滩土生土长的。长滩。是的。你什么时候产生表演热情或喜剧热情的？很小的时候，但我直到 26 岁结婚后才真正开始认真追求它
at 26. So that's when, you know, because my husband was like, yeah, do it, do it. I believe you can do this. No one else in my life thought I could. So he was working a couple of jobs while I was taking classes at the groundlings, and he would sit there and let me cut wigs on him and, you know, run lines with me and all this stuff. So I did the groundlings a lot. I took classes at South Coast rep, but I didn't go through the whole rep program. And then I just figured, well, I'll stay in ground lacing until they vote me out, because that's how it works there, you know. I didn't make it that far. How far did you go?
。所以那时，你知道的，因为我丈夫说，去吧，去吧。我相信你能做到。我生命中的其他人都不认为我能做到。所以他在打好几份工，而我在 Groundlings 上课，他坐在那里让我拿假发在他头上剪，你知道的，陪我对台词之类的。所以我经常去 Groundlings。我在南海岸剧团上过课，但我没有完成整个剧团项目。然后我想，好吧，我会一直呆在 Groundlings，直到他们投票让我离开，因为那里的规矩就是这样，你知道的。我没走那么远。你走了多远？
Lab, right, is before you go to, and then I had to, I got put on a list of repeat lab. Uh-huh. And I just never went back. I went to Improv Olympic. I started doing Longform Improv, the Herald at Improv Olympic while I was on the wait list thinking I would always go back, like, oh, I'll do this while I wait. Yeah. And then I just kind of met my people.
实验室，对吧，是在你去之前，然后我不得不，我被列入了重复实验室的名单。嗯哼。我再也没有回去。我去了即兴奥林匹克。当我在等待名单上以为我总是会回去的时候，我开始做长篇即兴表演，即兴奥林匹克的先驱，就像，哦，我在等待的时候做这个。是的。然后我差不多遇到了我的人。
Yeah. And I loved it. And then I just stayed there and rode that out. And I was still doing shows there, even when the office started. And that's where I met Kate Flannery. No kidding. Because we were in the show together called Bitch Planet. Oh, what?
是的。我喜欢它。然后我只是呆在那里，把那个坚持下来。当《办公室》开拍时，我还在那里演出。这就是我遇到凯特·弗兰内里的地方。真的吗？因为我们一起出演了一个叫《婊子星球》的节目。哦，什么？
Yeah. Oh, my God. I bet that was edgy. Sundays at 10 p.m. No parking. Don't you miss those days, though? Like, it was so fun. It was so fun.
是的。哦，天哪。我敢说那一定很前卫。星期天晚上 10 点。没停车位。不过，难道你不怀念那些日子吗？就像，太有趣了。太有趣了。
Doing these silly little shows and begging people to come. Yeah. You know, getting so many parking tickets. But, yeah, so I, I, so you were going to just stay there and ride it out. Yeah, and like when my time's up, my time's up. But then I got in the company, which was nice. But then I started working, and I couldn't do as many shows as I wanted to. So, but that's how that happened.
表演这些愚蠢的小节目，求着别人来看。是的。你知道，吃了那么多罚单。但是，是的，所以，我，所以，你打算就呆在那里坚持下去。是的，就像当我的时间到了，我的时间就到了。但后来我进了公司，这挺好的。但后来我开始工作了，我不能像我想要的那样做那么多演出。所以，但这就是那样发生的。
And then I was very frustrated because I thought, well, maybe I started this too late. I'm not really getting anywhere. I don't have an agent. everybody would be in the dressing room talking about all the auditions they were going on. And I was like, well, I didn't even get a phone call because I, you know, I don't have anyone repping me. And anyway, so I subbed for someone in a show, and that's how I got discovered to go audition for Reno. Right.
然后我非常沮丧，因为我想，好吧，也许我开始得太晚了。我真的没有取得任何进展。我没有经纪人。每个人都在化妆室里谈论他们去参加的所有试镜。而我觉得，好吧，我甚至没有接到电话，因为我，你知道，我没有人代表我。总之，我代替别人在演出里演了一个角色，这就是我被发现去为雷诺试镜的原因。对。
And that worked out. How were you when you got Reno? So I was probably 32. Yeah. Does that feel kind of like a big? Milestone break. Yeah. Yeah, that was a big deal.
结果成功了。你演雷诺的时候多大？所以我大概 32 岁。是的。那感觉像是一个重要的里程碑突破吗？对。是的，那是一件大事。
That was a big deal. It's so funny, Wendy. Thank you. I'm such a fan. But it was like, you know, basic cable. Yeah. No one thought, I mean, it was like just going and doing arts and crafts with your friends, you know. But I feel like people keep finding it, don't you?
那可真是件大事。太搞笑了，温迪。谢谢你。我是你的超级粉丝。但这就好像是，你知道的，基础有线电视。对。没有人觉得，我的意思是，这就像和你的朋友们一起去玩手工艺品一样，你知道的。但我觉得人们一直在发现它，不是吗？
It's never been off the air. Yeah. Like your show, we'll never be off the air. Yeah. So people keep coming to. it in waves. And it's always a new discovery. And is it coming back? Is the office coming back? In a new form. Okay. Yeah. It's like the documentary film crew has found a new subject and it's a small newspaper company. That's kind of just dying this paper industry. Yeah. Yeah. So it's like the
它从来没有停播过。对。就像你们的节目，永远不会停播。对。所以人们一波又一波地发现它。而且它总是充满新的发现。它会回归吗？办公室还会回归吗？以一种新的形式。好的。对。就像是纪录片摄制组发现了一个新题材，是一家小型报社。就是那种正在消亡的纸媒行业。对。对。所以就像是
idea is that it's like the same people who made the documentary of Dundra Mifflin are making this documentary of the small paper company and following the employees the way they did before. But there's not currently any, like, it's not our characters. Like Pam Beasley doesn't show up. Oh, gotcha. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
这个想法是，制作丹德尔·米夫林纪录片的同一拨人，现在正在制作这家小型报社的纪录片，并像以前一样跟踪拍摄员工。但目前没有任何类似的东西，比如这不是我们的角色。比如帕姆·比斯利不会出现。哦，明白了。好的。对。对。
So the through line is the documentary crew, not the people from Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. Oh, that's interesting. Yeah. I feel like Reno 911 also has the benefit of being very, like, you can make really fun clips out of it. It pops up on my Instagram all the time. I mean, how many times have I seen your bit where you're doing the – you know what I'm going to say, probably, the dancing – D-U-I pull over.
所以主线是纪录片摄制组，而不是来自邓德·米夫林的人。哦，这很有趣。对。我觉得《雷诺911》也有一个好处，就是它非常适合剪辑成好玩的短片。它总是弹到我的Instagram上。我的意思是，我到底看过多少次你那个桥段——你正在做那个——你大概知道我要说什么，就是那个跳舞——酒驾靠边停车。
The D-U-I thing, yeah. And that was one of the first things I ever did for that show. Really? Which is crazy. Oh, that lives everywhere. That lives everywhere. And then we got to – you guys remember when Quibi came out, right? Oh, sure.
酒驾那个，对。那是我为那个节目做的第一批事情之一。真的吗？太疯狂了。哦，那个到处都在流传。那个到处都在流传。然后我们有机会——你们还记得奎比（Quibi）刚出来的时候吗？哦，当然。
Oh, right. Yes. So we got to resurrect it a little bit. And because of that, we, you know, we did a bunch of other episodes that folded while we were on set. Oh, my gosh. But the checks were, it went out of business whilst we were filming. But we just kept going because we figured, well, someone's going to pick it up. So then we knocked out a bunch of episodes and two more movies.
哦，对的，没错。所以我们得以让它复活了一点。正因如此，我们，你知道的，在我们拍摄期间还顺便拍了其他好几集。哦，天哪。但支票，我们在拍摄时它就倒闭了。但我们还是坚持拍下去，因为我们想，总会有人接盘的。于是我们赶拍了好几集和另外两部电影。
So it's like the gift that keeps giving and whatever. I mean, I'm thrilled that I get to, you know, hang out and play with my friends. But it's just weird how things are cyclical like that. And I don't know. Yeah. Very fun. Well, I have a question for you.
所以这就好像是源源不断的惊喜什么的。我的意思是，我很高兴能，你知道的，和我的朋友们一起闲逛和玩耍。但事情就是这样周而复始，感觉真怪。我不知道。对。非常有趣。好吧，我有个问题要问你。
It comes from Christine M. in Ann Arbor, Michigan. Okay. She says, for this episode, did you have to handle a lot of Steve Currell's ad-libbing? And if so, do you recall, which was the scene that was the hardest for you to get through? Like, did you guys break? I don't remember breaking. I do remember him ad-living a little bit while he was just asking questions
它来自密歇根州安阿伯市的克里斯蒂娜·M。好的。她说，对于这一集，你不得不应付史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的大量即兴发挥吗？如果是这样，你还记得哪一场戏是你最难熬过去的吗？比如说，你们笑场了吗？我不记得我笑场过。我确实记得他在提问时进行了一点即兴发挥
because he was so thrilled to be with a concierge. You know? Her vast knowledge of like where you can get your dry cleaning done. Winnipegian, you know, hot spots. Well, you know, and after I visited Winnipeg, that whole thing became so much more funny to me because there's just nothing there. But I remember thinking,
因为能和一位礼宾员在一起，他太兴奋了。你知道吗？她对在哪里能干洗衣服有着渊博的知识。温尼伯人，你知道的，热门去处。好吧，你知道的，在我访问温尼伯之后，整件事对我来说变得好笑多了，因为那里根本什么都没有。但我记得当时我想，
don't break because you are lucky to be here. So do not break. And Steve never breaks. He never breaks. And Oscar never breaks. And you had to be in scenes with both of them. Ed Helms will break. Ed does. Yeah. But those two are like statues. And Oscar is a machine. Yeah. Because he had a recurring thing on Reno. Yes. And he would say these things. And I would be like having a nose bleak. trying not to laugh. Like, I'm gonna, I'm gonna have an aneurysm if I can't let this out. And when someone raises the bar like that,
千万别笑场，因为你能来这里已经很幸运了。所以千万别笑场。而且史蒂夫从来不笑场。他从不笑场。奥斯卡也从不笑场。而你必须和他们两个演对手戏。埃德·赫尔姆斯会笑场。埃德确实会。对。但那两个人就像雕像一样。而且奥斯卡简直就是个机器。对。因为他在《雷诺》里有一个常驻角色。是的。他会说那些台词。我当时就像是要流鼻血一样
you just can't. And I'm a giggler, but damn it, I'm not gonna do it. I'm not gonna ruin a take. Well, we've shared, like, we had to stop making eye contact with Steve. So, like, I don't know if you can really track where our eyes were, but I would look at his neck.
极力忍住不笑。就像，如果我再不释放出来，我就会得动脉瘤。当有人把标准抬得这么高时，
And like, if I looked in his eyes, I was a goner. Yeah. That surprises me, because you two were so, like in the moment. I don't know. I'm very surprised to hear that you guys were our breakers. There's a lot of, there's a lot of footage that they have for the blooper reel with me
你根本笑不出来。我本来是个爱笑的人，但该死的，我才不干。我才不会毁了一个镜头。好吧，我们分享过，比如我们不得不避免和史蒂夫进行眼神接触。所以，比如，我不知道你能不能真看出我们的视线落在哪里，但我会看着他的脖子。
and Angela, because we would crack up a lot. Well, we couldn't be next to each other. It was that sort of cumulative thing, because if I even felt her shoulder, you know, I'd be like, oh, yeah. So then they just started putting us apart. I feel like concierge Marie and Pam have a similar thing, which is that we had to play it totally straight against Steve's zaniness. Yeah. You know, like we had to just like stare at him.
而且，如果我看着他的眼睛，我就死定了。是的。这让我很惊讶，因为你们两个在当时的状态都非常投入。我不知道。听到你们两个才是笑场大王，我非常惊讶。在NG花絮里，有很多很多的素材都是关于我和
Yeah. And you stare at him so well. But why do you think she hooked up with him? We actually got a question about it. Yeah. Here, somebody said, oh, yeah, a few people wrote in. Tara F from Tustin, California said, I need to. understand more about concierge Marie. Why was she in the bar alone? Why is she attracted to
安吉拉的，因为我们经常笑崩。好吧，我们不能靠得太近。这是一种累积效应，因为如果我哪怕感觉到她的肩膀，你知道的，我就会觉得，哦，天哪。所以后来他们开始把我们分开。我觉得礼宾员玛丽和帕姆有一点很相似，那就是我们必须在史蒂夫的古怪行为面前保持绝对的正经。对。你知道的，就像我们必须直勾勾地盯着他。
Michael? Was she having a bad day at the concierge desk and Michael made her feel seen? Well, there is this moment. Yes, to all of that. You nailed it. There is a moment when you go back and rewatch it when he says, you know, after meeting concierge Marie that if you ever get to meet a concierge, it is intoxicating. And the camera rack focus and pushes in on you. And and you look bored out of your fucking mind. You were just like... It's so great. It's so perfect.
对。而且你盯着他看得很到位。但你觉得她为什么会和他勾搭上呢？我们实际上收到了关于这个的问题。对了。这里，有人说，哦，对了，好几个人写信来问。加利福尼亚州塔斯坦的塔拉·F说，我需要
Well, I think the listener who asked that question really nailed it. And again, in hotels, I used to see employees just drinking alone after work. You know, when you don't have anything to do and you can't make the drive home before you get a drink, you got to get a drink at 5.01. You know what I mean? I mean, and the bar is right there. It's right there and you get a discount and something might happen. You know, I think it was boredom.
更多地了解礼宾员玛丽。她为什么独自在酒吧？为什么她会被迈克尔吸引？是因为她在礼宾台度过了糟糕的一天，而迈克尔让她觉得自己被关注了吗？好吧，确实有这样一个时刻。是的，所有的这一切。你全说对了。当你回去重看的时候，有一个时刻是这样的：在遇到礼宾员玛丽之后，他说，如果你有机会遇到一位礼宾员，那真是让人陶醉。然后镜头变焦并拉近推向你。
I think it was like, well, there are worse things I could be doing. Yeah. But then I, you know, listen, she threw his shoes out into the hall. I think it didn't go well once they got behind that door. Empty calories. Oh, yeah, yeah. Did you do a little bit of a Canadian accent for concierge? Marie, we got mail, and I think I heard it.
而你看起来一副无聊透顶的样子。你就像是……太棒了。太完美了。
Well, there is that kind of... I was trying to do how I hear it. Yeah. And that French-Canadian accent is a little nasal. Yeah. And, okay, dry cleaners. Like, it's clipped in a weird way. Now, maybe I just sounded like someone with a speech impediment.
好吧，我觉得提出那个问题的听众真的抓住了精髓。而且话说回来，在酒店里，我经常看到员工下班后独自喝酒。你知道的，当你没什么事可做，在喝上一杯之前又没办法开车回家时，你必须在5点01分喝上一杯。你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，酒吧就在那儿。它就在那儿，你还能打折，而且可能会发生点什么。你知道的，我觉得这就是无聊。
But that's how I hear that accent. So, I don't know. Yeah. I'm not saying it was good. I'm saying that I did that. Yeah. No, I liked it. I liked it. I one time did a press junket in Montreal, and the gal that showed us around had sort of a similar sound. Yeah. And it was kind of a way she went up on the end of her words. Yeah. You know? Yes. Yeah. I thought it was great. Thank you. I'll put that on my special skills section.
我觉得这就像是，好吧，还有比这更糟的事我可以做。对。但随后我，你知道的，听着，她把他的鞋子扔到了走廊里。我觉得一旦他们关上那扇门，事情就进展得不顺利了。空热量。哦，对了，对了。你给礼宾员玛丽加了一点加拿大口音吗？玛丽，我们收到信了，我想我听出来了。
Special skills. Put it right next to roller skating. And that was my special skills. We're so bad always. Do you have special skills? Like back in the day when you had that resume, what were your special skills? I am a pretty good roller skater. Okay. That's not a joke. I am too. I love roller skating.
好吧，确实有那种……我只是在模仿我听到的声音。是的。那种法裔加拿大口音带点鼻音。是的。而且，好吧，干洗店。听起来像是有一种奇怪的断音。现在，也许我听起来只是像个有言语障碍的人。
I love roller skating. What kind of skates do you have? Girl, I got my roller skates. Holy crap, in the 90s in Huntington Beach at a roller skating shop that I'm sure doesn't even exist anymore. And they're like the old brown suede. Stop. And I'm on my, I don't know, third set of wheels. I'm southern sometimes.
但那就是我听到的那种口音。所以，我不知道。是的。我不是说它有多好。我是说我确实那么做了。是的。不，我挺喜欢的。我挺喜欢的。我有一次在蒙特利尔做新闻发布会，带我们参观的那位姑娘听起来也有点类似的声音。是的。而且她在词尾上扬的方式挺特别的。对。你知道吗？是的。对。我觉得挺棒的。谢谢。我要把这个写进我的特殊技能栏里。
I'm on my third set of wheels, and they're the wide ones because I like to be outside on my skates. Indoor skates are more slick. And that's fine. I'll go to a roller rink. That's fine. But I like the wheels that are made for outside. And then I have the big front stopper. Oh, that's smart.
特殊技能。把它写在旱冰滑华旁边。那就是我的特殊技能。我们总是这么糟糕。你有什么特殊技能吗？就像当年你写简历的时候，你的特殊技能是什么？我旱冰滑得挺好的。好的。这不是开玩笑。我也是。我超喜欢旱冰滑华。
And then I have the little one on the back. I don't use it as much. You have one on the back? Yeah. Yeah, that you can drag if you're going. Oh, wow. I know. That's hardcore.
我超喜欢旱冰。你有什么样的旱冰鞋？天哪，我的旱冰鞋是在90年代亨廷顿海滩的一家旱冰鞋店买的，那家店现在肯定不存在了。它们是那种老式的棕色麂皮的。等等。而且我正用着我的，我不知道，第三套轮子。我有的时候挺南方风情的。
But I don't use it very often. I have some pink suede moxies. Oh, moxies. Those are nice. Yeah. I mean, I have a few other pairs, too. I have some sparkly ones that Jessica Simpson sent me. Did you know she made roller skates?
我正用着我的第三套轮子，而且它们是宽轮子，因为我喜欢在户外滑冰。室内旱冰鞋更滑一些。这倒没关系。我去溜冰场也行。这没问题。但我喜欢专为户外制造的轮子。然后我前面有个很大的刹车塞。哦，那很聪明。
I did not. My mind is blown. Uh-huh. Yeah. Ladies, can I say something right now? Yes. Is there like a movie? like part improv where you play sisters who roller skate?
然后我后面有一个小一点的。我没那么常用它。你后面有一个？对。对，如果你在移动的话，你可以用它来拖行。哦，哇。我知道。那挺硬核的。
I mean, is this meant to be? I think, Jenna, you are on to something. Right? I'm seeing it. You're seeing a vision. I don't know. I mean, I will come skate through the halls of St. Dennis Medical with you. I mean, and we want this.
我的意思是，这是命中注定的吗？我觉得，珍娜，你这话很有道理，对吧？我看到了。你看到了一个愿景。我不知道。我的意思是，我要和你一起去圣丹尼斯医学中心的走廊里滑冰。我的意思是，我们想要这个。
You too. Look at you. Look at us. We should be skating together. We should be. Okay, sorry. I got very excited. I got very excited about roller skating.
你也是。看看你。看看我们。我们应该一起滑冰。我们应该这样。好吧，抱歉。我太兴奋了。我对轮滑感到非常兴奋。
Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fairs, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday anywhere along the Go network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of Buy your online GoPASS ahead of the show at go-transit.com slash tickets. Wendy's most important deal of the day has a fresh lineup. Pick any two breakfast items for $4. New four-piece French toast sticks, bacon or sausage wrap, biscuit or English muffin sandwiches, small hot coffee, and more. Limited time only at participating Wendy's Taxes Extra.
乘坐Go Transit前往多伦多百威舞台和新罗杰斯体育场等主要场馆。多亏了Go Transit特惠的在线电子客票，10加元的周末一日通票可在任何周末或假日提供Go网络沿线的无限次换乘。平日团体票也提供同样的平日出行灵活性，两人起价30加元，最多60元可供一个团体使用。请在演出前于go-transit.com/tickets购买您的在线GoPASS。温蒂汉堡最重要的每日优惠迎来了全新阵容。任选两款早餐只需4元。全新四件套法式吐司条、培根或香肠卷、饼干或英式松饼三明治、小杯热咖啡等等。限时优惠，仅限参与活动的温蒂汉堡，税费另计。
I'm Chris Hadfield. I'm an astronaut, an author, a citizen of planet Earth. Join me for a six-part journey into the systems that power. the world. Real conversations with real people who are shaping the future of energy. No politics, no empty talk, just solutions focused conversations on the challenges we must overcome and the possibilities that lie ahead. This is on energy. Listen wherever you get your podcasts. You know, speaking of St. Dennis Medical, we got a lot of letters from people who are fans. And of you specifically, we have started watching it.
我是克里斯·哈德菲尔德。我是一名宇航员、作家、地球村的公民。和我一起踏上为世界提供动力的系统的六集旅程。与塑造能源未来的真实人物进行真正的对话。没有政治，没有空谈，只有专注于我们必须克服的挑战和未来可能性的解决方案对话。这就是能源节目。在您获取播客的任何地方收听。你知道，说到圣丹尼斯医学中心，我们收到了很多粉丝的来信。关于你本人，我们已经开始观看了。
We love it. It's so good. Thank you. What a phenomenal cast. Thank you. You just got picked up for season two. Congratulations. Thank you.
我们很喜欢。太棒了。谢谢。多么棒的演员阵容。谢谢。你们刚刚续订了第二季。恭喜。谢谢。
Thank you. What can you tell us about working on it? Well, you guys know Justin. Mm-hmm. Justin Spitzer. And he is the loveliest man. So wonderful. Such a nice person.
谢谢。关于这部剧的创作，你能告诉我们什么吗？好吧，你们认识贾斯汀。嗯哼。贾斯汀·斯皮策。他是最可爱的人。太棒了。是个非常好的人。
Yeah. And for your listeners that have watched St. Dennis, Justin was in our episode where we had a guy, a performer come and do something for our pediatrics ward, and he's the one that did a somersault and juggled and then walked off stage. That was our Justin. I need to ask you about in the very first episode where you do a cartwheel. Right. And everyone makes an audible like, yes. Was that scripted? No. You just can do cartwheels? I'm so impressed. I can't do a cartwheel at my age. But you can. You can. If you just decide to do it and you do it. Because what had been told to me by our showrunner Eric, he came in and whispered in my ear, just be a real cheerleader about it. So I said, okay, I used to be a cheerleader. So that's what I'll do. So that's how I interpreted it. And he said later, well, that's not what I meant, but that's, was funny.
是的。对于看过《圣丹尼斯》的听众来说，贾斯汀曾出现在我们的剧集里，当时我们有一个表演者来为我们的儿科病房做些事情，他就是那个做侧手翻、杂耍然后走下舞台的人。那就是我们的贾斯汀。我得问你关于第一集里你做一个侧手翻的事。对。每个人都发出了“哇”的赞叹。那是剧本安排的吗？不是。你只是会做侧手翻？我太印象深刻了。我这个年纪已经不会做侧手翻了。但你会。你会的。只要你决定去做，你就能做到。因为我们的剧展运作人埃里克告诉我，他走过来在我耳边说，表现得像个热情的拉拉队队长就行。所以我说，好吧，我以前是个啦啦队员。所以这就是我要做的。这就是我理解的方式。他后来回来说，好吧，我不是那个意思，不过那也挺搞笑的。
I mean, you really went for it. Yeah, I went for it. You do sell it. Well, listen, when you are trying to motivate a staff because you did something really dumb, like buy a mammogram machine that you forget, oh, wait, maybe, A, we can't afford it, and B, oh, yeah, I have to plug it in. And I don't know if we can handle all this stuff. You're going to do anything to divert away from your stupidity, right?
我的意思是，你真的是全力以赴。是的，我全力以赴。你演得很投入。好吧，听着，当你试图激励员工时，因为你做了一件非常愚蠢的事，比如买了一台乳腺钼靶机，结果你忘了，哦，等等，也许，第一，我们买不起，第二，哦，对，我得把它插上电源。而且我不知道我们能不能应付这一切。你会做任何事来转移对你愚蠢行为的注意力，对吧？
So she's being a cheerleader. She's trying to get everybody out there. Come on, let's be happy. Let's put on our game faces and heal some people. It's so great. But it also, like, it breaks your heart sometimes. Like, it gets real real, you know, in a way that is something that I always loved about the office, too, was that undercurrent of, like, real.
所以她在扮演啦啦队员。她试图把每个人都调动起来。来吧，让我们开心点。让我们打起精神来，去治愈一些人。这太棒了。但它有时也让人心碎。就像它变得非常真实一样，你知道的，这也是我一直很喜欢《办公室》的一点，那就是那种真实的潜台词。
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Oh, yeah. I've cried so many tears watching the office because there's always. something at the end that's like, and it's just a look or a turn of phrase where you're like, oh, that got me, that got me. These are real people. This is a real situation. Like, work families, it's important. You know, those are, you spend more time with your work family than you do with your real family, unfortunately. And, you know, even in the pilot, Allison Tolman's
嗯哼。嗯哼。哦，是的。我看《办公室》时流了好多眼泪，因为最后总会有一些东西，比如一个眼神或一句话，让你觉得，哦，这戳中了我，这戳中了我。这些都是真人。这是一个真实的处境。就像职场家庭一样，这很重要。你知道，不幸的是，你花在职场家庭上的时间比花在真正家庭上的时间还要多。而且，你知道，甚至在试播集中，艾莉森·托尔曼的
character, which I met Allison one time, we both went to the same university, not at the same time. I know, I'm a dinosaur. Stop it. Stop it. You're very young. But she is so talented, and she's struggling throughout her day to try to make it to her daughter's play, right? And boy, did I feel that. I felt that so hard. It was like I felt it viscerally, like the stakes.
角色——我见过艾莉森一次，我们上过同一所大学，但不是同一时期。我知道，我是个恐龙。住手。住手。你很年轻。但她太有才华了，她在这一天里挣扎着想要赶上她女儿的戏剧演出，对吧？天哪，我太能感同身受了。我感同身受得太深了。就像我由内而外地感受到那种紧迫性。
And I think that's what I like about the show is that there are real stakes. But then it's so incredibly funny. I mean, what a gift. I, it was pretty delicious when I read that pilot script. It was like, yeah, I think I got to do this. Yeah. I think I got to do this. This is funny.
我想这就是我喜欢这部剧的原因，因为有真实的赌注。但随后它又极其有趣。我的意思是，真是个天赋。当我读到那个试播集剧本时，感觉非常美妙。当时就觉得，是的，我想我得拍这个。是的。我想我得拍这个。这太搞笑了。
So funny. And I have to ask you about working with Steve Little because I worked with him as well on haters back off. And it might be, I told Jenna this when I was doing that show at the time, maybe of all the other times I've laughed so hard, which would have been in a conference room in the office when Steve Krell was doing his thing. and we could all barely keep it together. The second hardest I've ever laughed on a set was with Steve Little when him and I had this weird romance and we had a date in a bathtub, but there was no water in a bathtub, and we were, anyway, it was ridiculous.
太搞笑了。我得问问你和史蒂夫·利特合作的感受，因为我也曾在《海特斯倒霉史》中跟他合作过。这可能是——我当时拍那部剧时对珍娜说过——除了我在《办公室》的会议室里，当史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在搞笑，我们所有人都快憋不住笑的那次之外，我在片场笑得第二厉害的一次，就是和史蒂夫·利特在一起。当时我和他有一段奇怪的浪漫，我们在浴缸里约会，但浴缸里没有水，我们——总之，太荒谬了。
But he is so funny. He's so amazing. He is so funny, and he was my good luck charm at the groundlings. He really was. In The Sunday Company, if I was struggling, I knew if I write something with Steve, it will get on stage and it will be a hit. I knew this. And I just love that guy.
但他太搞笑了。他太棒了。他太搞笑了，而且他在格朗德剧团是我的幸运符。真的是这样。在周日剧团里，如果我陷入困境，我知道只要我和史蒂夫一起写点东西，它就能登上舞台并大获成功。我对此深信不疑。我就是喜欢那家伙。
Like, I've tried to bring him wherever I am. Like, wherever I can shove him in, I try to do that. We did, like, a dramatic film and played husband and wife. It's called Blush. It was just a little festival film, but he's so, such a gift. And, like, every time I, you know how sometimes you recommend people and you think, oh, God, maybe I shouldn't have done that? Maybe, oh, I hope they don't embarrass me or anything.
就像，我试着无论走到哪里都带着他。只要我能把他塞进什么地方，我都会尽量去做。我们拍过一部剧情片，扮演夫妻。片名叫《红晕》。那只是一部小型的电影节短片，但他真的是个天才。而且，你知道，每次你——你知道有时候你向别人推荐某人，然后你会想，哦，天哪，也许我不该那样做？也许，哦，我希望他们不要让我出丑或者别的什么。
Every time I recommend him, I get thank you calls from people like, oh, he just elevated everything we did. And, yeah, he's so great. I love that you love him. He's a good guy. Wendy, I can't believe we haven't discussed your kissing scene with Steve Carell, where Michael and Concierge Marie are just making out in an alley at night. I don't.
每次我推荐他，我都会接到别人的感谢电话，比如，哦，他提升了我们所做的一切的高度。而且，是的，他太棒了。我喜欢你喜欢他。他是个好人。温蒂，我真不敢相信我们还没聊过你和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的吻戏，迈克尔和礼宾员玛丽在晚上的小巷里旁若无人地热吻。我不——
What is going on? which was delightful. And I highly recommend it. He is a good kisser. And for the audience at home, one thing that you don't want to be doing, and I'm sure you guys have experienced this when you've had to make out with people on different sets, is like sometimes, oh, how do I want to say this? There's like an unspoken thing of like, don't shove your tongue in somebody's mouth.
这到底是怎么回事？这太令人愉快了。我强烈推荐。他是一个很好的接吻高手。对于家里的观众来说，有一件事你绝对不想做——我相信你们在不同的片场拍吻戏时也经历过——那就是有时，哦，我该怎么说呢？有一种不成文的规定，就是不要把舌头塞进别人的嘴里。
Just make it look like you're chomping. Stage kissing. Stage kissing. Some people don't know how to do that. Yeah. And you leave going, oh, gross, what am I going to? Oh, God. I got to go to the doctor right away.
只需假装你在咀嚼。舞台之吻。舞台之吻。有些人不知道该怎么做。是的。然后你离开时会想，哦，太恶心了，我该怎么办？哦，天哪。我得马上去看医生。
Where's the mouthwash? Where's the pine sall? I don't know. But, yeah, he was delightful, and it was, you know, quick and dirty, and it wasn't uncomfortable at all. And, you know, you always feel weird when you're married and someone else is married. Like, it's a character thing. But still, you don't want to step on toes.
漱口水在哪？松木清洁剂在哪？我不知道。但是，是的，他很讨人喜欢，而且，你知道，速战速决，一点也不让人感到不舒服。而且，你知道，当你已婚而别人也已婚时，你总是会觉得怪怪的。这只是个角色需要。不过，你仍然不想踩到别人的界限。
No. So you're just like, hi, nice to meet you. Nice to make out with you. Yeah. I did a kissing scene with a very famous and handsome actor once. And so I went to do the scene. Uh-huh. The way they kissed me was really odd.
没有。所以你只会说，嗨，很高兴认识你。很高兴和你接吻。是的。我曾和一个非常著名且帅气的演员拍过一场吻戏。于是我去拍那场戏。嗯哼。他们吻我的方式真的很奇怪。
Oh, no. And it was like this like sort of like, it was like, I mean, I'm going to do it for you guys, but nobody can see it. But it's like, it's like, like, hum. Oh, like he was eating a steak. A little bit like there was like a person, like a really pursing the lips out. This is like a horse. Ooh, okay. Going for a carrot.
噢，不。就像这种，呃，这就像——我的意思是，我要为你们表演一下，但没人能看见。但它就像，它就像，像，嗯。噢，就像他在吃牛排。有点像有个人，把嘴唇撅得很高。这就像一匹马。噢，好吧。奔向一根胡萝卜。
Yes. Yes. Like when it nibbles at something. And I was like, that is so weird. I have seen this person kiss in other things. And it always looks real smoldering. And so I went home and I told Lee about it. And he said to me, you know what?
是的。是的。就像它在啃什么东西一样。当时我就想，这太奇怪了。我见过这个人 在其他作品里接吻。看起来总是充满激情。所以我就回家把这事告诉了李。他对我说，你知道吗？
I bet this looks killer on camera. Because, of course, he's seeing it as a director, right? And I was like, do you think so? So we got out a phone and we kissed me and my husband the way we would normally kiss, right? The one that gives us all the feels. Right. And then we filmed ourselves doing the harm. wrong kiss right and we watched it back my husband was right oh really like lip kiss thing looked
我敢打赌这在镜头前看起来效果杀翻了。因为，当然，他是从导演的角度看的，对吧？然后我想，你真的这么觉得吗？于是我们拿出一个手机，我和我丈夫按照我们平时习惯的方式接吻，对吧？那种让我们充满感觉的方式。然后我们拍下了我们做那种诡异的错误吻法的视频，回放一看，我丈夫是对的。哦，真的吗？那个唇对唇的东西看起来
so sensual and amazing but to do it yeah was like not at all fun or also would never lead me to want to in real life yeah it would lead you to leaving it was correct and we were stunned and then when I saw it on screen, I was like, oh, really? I have two thoughts as this story is washing over me. One is, wouldn't you maybe just give someone a heads up like, hey, I'm going to kiss you. It's kind of like a over-pronounced kiss. Just get ready for it. I promise it looks good on camera.
太性感、太棒了，但实际做起来，呃，一点也不好玩，而且在现实生活中也绝对不会让我产生想亲的冲动。是的，这会让你想离开。这是对的，我们都惊呆了。然后当我在屏幕上看到它时，我想，哦，真的吗？当这个故事在脑海中浮现时，我有两个想法。一个是，你难道不会提前给别人打个招呼，比如，嘿，我要吻你了。这有点像一个夸张的吻。做好准备吧。我保证它在镜头前看起来很好看。
So then you're prepared. Because otherwise, like, what's it like on the receiving end of the horse butt? Yeah. Well, it was, listen, it was one of those things where. Like in Wendy's situation, it was a one-day job. Like, I had to show up. I had to kiss somebody. I had to get out of here.
这样你就有所准备了。否则，从马屁股的角度来看会是什么样的体验？是的。好吧，听着，那是那种情况。就像在温蒂的情况下，那是一天的工作。就像，我必须露面。我必须吻某人。我必须离开这里。
But that's very interesting, like the weird chomping, carrot eating, street corn eating. That looks good on. Super hot. And you tested this in your own laboratory, which I appreciate, you know. It is. That's amazing. Go home and try it. I'm going to.
但这很有趣，就像那些奇怪的咀嚼声、吃胡萝卜、吃街头玉米。看起来很不错。超级辣。而且你在自己的实验室里测试过这个，我很欣赏，你知道的。确实如此。这太棒了。回家试试吧。我这就去。
As you were talking about all that, I mean, when. Andy, I want you to know, I, this morning with, like, my cup of tea in my robe, under my blanket with all my weird rescue animals, I watched this YouTube clip called Best of Rita from Bridesmaids. Oh, yeah. I was laughing so hard. And, you know, my husband's an early riser. I'm not. He's already been to the gym and the grocery store, and he's coming in, all gym sweaty person. And I'm sitting on the couch in my robe with a cup of tea surrounded by animals.
当你在谈论这一切的时候，我的意思是，当。安迪，我想让你知道，我，今天早上拿着，就像，一杯茶，穿着浴袍，盖着毯子，身边还有我所有奇怪的救助动物，我看了一个YouTube剪辑，叫做《伴娘里的丽塔精选集》。哦，对。我笑得前仰后合。而且，你知道，我丈夫是个起得早的人。我不是。他已经去过健身房和杂货店了，然后他走进来，满身都是健身房的汗味。而我穿着浴袍坐在沙发上，端着一杯茶，周围都是动物。
I am laughing my ass off. And it's early. And he's like, what are you doing? And I was like, I'm just watching Wendy. Like the outtakes, you say this line, which is what made me think of this, you say to Ellie's character, you're talking about being married and having sex and stuff. And she said, so you guys don't really have sex anymore? And you were like, oh, no, we have sex all the time. He hasn't kissed me in five years.
我笑得合不拢嘴。而且还很早。他问，你在干什么？我说，我只是在看温蒂。就像花絮里那样，你说了这句台词，这让我联想到了这个，你对埃莉的角色说，你们在谈论结婚、做爱之类的事。她说，所以你们俩真的不再做爱了吗？而你说，哦，不，我们经常做爱。他已经五年没吻过我了。
And it just cracked me up. Yeah. Those are so delicious. Those outtakes from bridesmaids. Thank you. That looked like so much fun. I forgot about that. Oh, that was very fun.
这真的把我逗乐了。是啊。那些太精彩了。《伴娘》的那些花絮。谢谢。看起来太有趣了。我都忘了这事了。哦，那真的很有趣。
That was very fun. And you guys got to work with the glorious Ellie temper, who I have not seen in 12 years or whatever. But, you know, she seems to be doing well. She's doing great. Yeah. She's the sweetest. But it looked like they just set the camera up
那真的很有趣。而且你们有机会和光芒四射的埃莉·肯珀合作，我已经12年没见过她了，或者诸如此类。但是，你知道的，她看起来过得不错。她过得很好。是的。她人最好了。但看起来他们只是架起了相机
and let it roll on the two of you. And how many times you guys riffed different things? It's just brilliant. It's brilliant comedy. And Paul Figue. Paul Figue was such a big part of the office as well. And Paul dresses so well that you feel like, well, I have to listen to you. I know.
然后让它对着你们两个一直拍。你们即兴发挥了多少次不同的内容？这简直太棒了。这是绝妙的喜剧。还有保罗·费格。保罗·费格也是《办公室》很大的一部分。而且保罗穿得那么讲究，让你觉得，好吧，我得听你的。我知道。
You're the best dressed person here. He is the best dress person I know in my life. Like consistently best dressed. I wish I had that kind of confidence in myself or I don't know how to even say it. Like, I wish I cared that much to get up and put on an outfit every day. Just the willpower to make it happen every day is kind of amazing. Amazing. Well, as we are kind of getting ready to wrap up here, we're going to ask you our call sheet questions, but you've been in so many things, Wendy.
你是这里穿得最好的人。他是我这辈子认识的人中穿得最好看的。就像一直以来都穿得最好。我希望自己也有那种自信，或者我甚至不知道该怎么说。就像，我希望自己能那么在乎每天起床穿上一套衣服。每天都有这种意志力去做到这一点，简直有点不可思议。不可思议。好了，当我们准备在这里收尾时，我们要问你我们的演员表提问，但你演过太多作品了，温蒂。
Is there anything that stands out to you a favorite memory or project or person you've worked with? Oh, God. So many. Yeah. I, listen, I'm so lucky that I got to have George Siegel as my dad for eight seasons. Yeah. On the Goldbergs. Yeah.
有没有什么让你印象深刻的、最喜欢的记忆、项目或合作过的人？哦，天哪。太多了。是的。我，听着，我很幸运能在《戈德堡一家》里让乔治·西格尔当了八季的爸爸。是的。在《戈德堡一家》里。是的。
I was so lucky that I got to do that job at all. You know, that, I don't have kids. I got to have kids and get that out of my system. I got to live through the 80s again. and I got to work with probably 200 of the most amazing people that I will ever meet in my life. So, like, that was such a blessing. But having George Siegel, the legend, be my dad, and I got to stare into those big blue eyes on camera. Like, oh, I will be eternally grateful that I got to do that.
我很幸运能做那份工作。你知道的，我没有孩子。我能有孩子，并把那份母爱释放出来。我能再次经历80年代。我还能和大约200个我这辈子见过的最了不起的人合作。所以，这真的是一种祝福。但是能让传奇人物乔治·西格尔做我的爸爸，而且我能在镜头前凝视着那双巨大的蓝眼睛。就像，哦，我将永远感激我能做到这一点。
That was really fun for me. Yeah. And that show was 10 seasons. Yeah. I mean, I feel like we talk about this because a lot of life happens and that amount of time. Just you really do become a family, the cast and crew. Yeah. Oh, yeah. And so many, I mean, you guys know marriages, divorces, people getting sober, people having kids. Yeah. Losing family members, losing pets. Like, you're in it for everybody. And it's so special. that you crave those people when you're on hiatus. Yeah. Yes. You're like, I can't wait to go back and tell so-and-so from Transpo that I watch this game on TV. You know, like, you just, they're your buds. They're your buddies.
这对我来说真的很有趣。是的。而且那个节目播了10季。是的，我的意思是，我觉得我们谈论这个是因为在那么长的时间里发生了太多生活中的事情。你们真的变成了一家人，演员和剧组。是的。哦，是的。还有那么多，我的意思是，你们知道的，结婚、离婚、人们戒酒、人们生孩子。是的。失去家庭成员，失去宠物。就像，你参与了每个人的生活。这是如此特别。以至于在休假期间你会渴望见到那些人。是的。是的。你会想，我迫不及待地想回去告诉运输部门的某某人我在电视上看了这场比赛。你知道，就像，他们是你的死党。他们是你的哥们儿。
Yeah. So that's what I wish for every actor out there is to be able to have an amazing work situation like that, a long-running thing where you really get to bond with people because it's very, very special. It is. And then you wrap and you miss each other. And anytime you get to see each other, it's just like unbelievable. And then you text your best friend and you're like back and forth, when can we work together again? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then there's the reality of God, you really want to see everybody all the time and you really mean to get in touch and then five years go by. Well, yeah. It's just, you know, you do. That's the beauty of it. Yeah. All right. Well, here are our, call she questions. Let's start with number one. What was your first entertainment job?
是的。所以这就是我对外面所有演员的祝愿，能够拥有那样一个了不起的工作环境，一个长青的项目，让你真正与人建立深厚的联系，因为这是非常非常特殊的。确实如此。然后节目结束了，你们会互相想念。每当你们有机会见面时，就简直不可思议。然后你会给你的挚友发短信，发来发去，我们什么时候能再一起合作？是的。是的。是的。然后就是现实，天哪，你真的很想一直见到所有人，你也真心打算保持联系，然后五年就过去了。好吧，是的。这只是，你知道的，你会的。这就是它的美妙之处。是的。好吧。那么，这些是我们的演员表提问。让我们从第一个开始。你的第一份娱乐行业的工作是什么？
My first entertainment job, I believe I was, oh, it was a music video. It was a music video. What music video? This is so dumb. I was an extra in a Carmen Electra video. Oh my God, that's amazing. That is amazing. What did you have to do? do. Did you have to dance? Yeah, and we had to audition. It was like there were auditions and callbacks just to be extras to club dance in the background. It was so silly. And I believe I was paid $100 in cash, you guys, and that's not nothing. Uh-uh. Were you a clubber? Did you have that in your life? Not really. Full on faking it. I was faking it. I was faking it. You were hitting the Long Beach club scene? Not really.
我的第一份娱乐行业的工作，我想我是，哦，是一个音乐录影带。那是一个音乐录影带。什么音乐录影带？这太蠢了。我是卡门·伊莱克特拉的一个MV里的群演。哦天哪，这太棒了。这太棒了。你得做什么？做。你得跳舞吗？是的，我们还得去试镜。就像有试镜和复试，只是为了当背景里在夜店跳舞的群演。太蠢了。而且我相信我当时拿到了100美元现金，伙计们，这可不是小数目。嗯-嗯。你是个夜店咖吗？你的生活里有这部分吗？其实没有。完全是装出来的。我是装出来的。我是装出来的。你去过长滩的夜店吗？并没有。
And there were a lot of clubs, but I just never had any money. Oh, yeah, it's expensive. It's expensive to go out and drink, you know. Yeah, and like pay for the high-priced cocktails. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Number two, do you speak any other languages?
那里有很多夜店，但我从来没有钱。哦，是的，这很贵。出去喝酒很贵的，你知道的。是的，还要支付高昂的鸡尾酒费用。是的。是的。好吧。第二个问题，你会说其他语言吗？
I have taken German and French, and I can read it pretty well. I can't understand it. Okay. If someone's speaking it, unfortunately. But you can read it. I can read it. Has that come in handy ever? I did get to go to the Olympics this past summer.
我学过德语和法语，而且我阅读能力相当不错。我听不懂。好吧。如果有人在说的话，不幸的是。但你能阅读。我能阅读。这派上过用场吗？我今年夏天去参加奥运会了。
So, yeah, it came in a little bit handy. But I was also, like, too nervous to trust my instincts. So luckily, you know, we had guides and everything. Okay. Number three, what's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? I love New Orleans so much that I talked my husband into buying a condo there. Oh, wow. So we have the tiniest little condo.
所以，是的，稍微派上了一点用场。但我也，有点太紧张了，不敢相信自己的直觉。所以幸运的是，你知道的，我们有向导和一切。好吧。第三个问题，你去过哪个地方是你绝对热爱的？我太喜欢新月城（新奥尔良）了，以至于我劝说我丈夫在那里买了一套公寓。哦，哇。所以我们在
in the French Quarter. I love it. It's like living in the middle of Disneyland. It's so fun. That town just has a whole energy to it. Doesn't it? It's just so cool. Yeah.
法国区（French Quarter）拥有一个极小的公寓。我太喜欢了。就像住在迪士尼乐园的正中央一样。太有趣了。那座城镇本身就有一种全方位的能量。不是吗？简直酷毙了。是的。
I love it. And we go as often as we can. I mean, I love that you walk out in the morning. And there's music playing. Yeah. And people dancing. And people just might start dancing down the street. Yeah.
我太喜欢了。而且我们只要有机会就会去。我的意思是，我喜欢你早上出门的时候。到处都有音乐在播放。是的。还有人在跳舞。人们可能随时会在街上跳起舞来。是的。
I was fortunate enough I did two movies there, but I have family from Louisiana. I just loved on the days that I had off. I would just go walk, and you always saw something. It's kind of like when you tell me stories, Jenna, about Manhattan. Like, do you always see something? Yeah. Do you have, like, a favorite food from there?
我很幸运在那里拍了两部电影，但我有亲戚来自路易斯安那州。我只是喜欢在我休息的日子里。我就会去散步，你总能看到一些东西。这就有点像你跟我讲的故事，珍娜，关于曼哈顿的。就像，你总是能看到一些东西吗？是的。你有什么，比如那里最喜欢的食物吗？
Like, are you into the cuisine as well? I'm not into the cuisine that much. I don't eat shellfish or fish of any kind, so that takes a lot of it off the table. But listen, just give me some red beans and rice, and I am happy. I do like really hot food. There's really good chicken gumbo that, you know, because you don't always have to have, like, the gumbo with everything in it. Right. There's a great gumbo at Herb Saints.
比如你也对那里的美食感兴趣吗？我对那里的美食没那么感兴趣。我不吃贝类或任何种类的鱼，所以这就排除了很多选项。但是听着，只要给我一些红豆饭，我就很高兴了。我确实喜欢很辣的食物。有一种非常好吃的鸡肉秋葵汤，你知道的，因为你并不总是非得吃那种什么都有的秋葵汤。没错。在 Herb Saints 有一款很棒的秋葵汤。
Okay. It's my favorite restaurant in New Orleans. Steve's on, turned me on to it because he did Tramee there for like five seasons. I tell every single person that I know going to New Orleans to go to Herb Saints. Oh, okay. We're going to go next time. I will give you the info. Like, that would be so fun.
好吧。这是我在新月城最喜欢的餐厅。史蒂夫把我带到那儿去的，因为他在那里演了大约五季的《崔美》（Treme）。我向我认识的每一个要去新月城的人推荐 Herb Saints。哦，好吧。我们下次要去。我会把信息给你。这会非常有趣。
Where you live there? I don't think I could live there for a long time. How did you discover it? Um, my sister and I went, we just needed to have a sister's weekend, and she had been there. She said, oh, you're going to love it. I went there with my sister, had the most amazing time, but also felt like, did I live here in a past life or something? Something about it felt very familiar to me.
你在那里住过吗？我觉得我在那儿住不了太久。你是怎么发现这个地方的？嗯，我和我姐姐去了，我们只是需要一个姐妹周末，她以前去过那里。她说，哦，你会爱上那里的。我和我姐姐一起去了那里，度过了一段最棒的时光，但也觉得，我是在前世住过这里还是怎么着？那里的某些东西让我觉得非常熟悉。
Mm-hmm. And I like walking down the street and you kind of feel like you know everybody. I can't explain it, but there's, there was just so many freaks there. Yeah, I love people who are just like super. friendly, and I don't know, I'll take it from there. I won't take it from everywhere. Yeah. But every time you walk down the street, to your point, there's something weird going on. You're going to see something that you weren't expecting. Always. You know? And is it haunted? Yes. But we won't get into that now. That's a different podcast. Yes. But, you know, a friend of mine has
嗯哼。而且我喜欢走在街上，你会有种认识每一个人的感觉。我很难解释，但那里有，那里有太多的怪咖了。是的，我喜欢那些超级友好的人，而且，我不知道，我从那儿开始。我不会从每个地方都开始。是的。但是每次你走在街上，正如你所说，总会有一些奇怪的事情发生。你会看到一些你意想不到的事情。总是如此。你知道吗？而且那儿闹鬼吗？是的。但我们现在不讨论这个。那是另一个播客。是的。但是，你知道的，我的一个朋友有
this theory. He's a comedy writer. And the first time he went to London, he was like, I kind of like, I can't explain it exactly, but I felt it in my bone. Like, I think my people were here at some time. He said, I just felt so grounded in this place that I've never lived in. Yeah. And I don't know. I feel like that's how I feel about New York City. Really? I don't know what it is.
这样一个理论。他是一个喜剧编剧。他第一次去伦敦的时候，他说，我有点喜欢，我无法确切解释，但我在骨子里感受到了。就像，我觉得我的人在某个时期就在这里。他说，我只是在这个我从未居住过的地方感到了如此踏实。是的。而且我不知道。我觉得我对纽约市也是这种感觉。真的吗？我不知道为什么。
I didn't go there until I was 26 years old. Uh-huh. I didn't fall in love with it until my 30s. But there's a piece of me that makes sense there. And it doesn't, it's never made sense anywhere else in the world. Have you lived there ever or did you? I have a little bit. Yeah, but short periods of time, but I hope to retire there. It's my happy place.
我直到26岁才去那里。嗯哼。直到30多岁我才爱上它。但我身上有一部分在那里说得通。而且它从来没有在世界上任何其他地方说得通。你在那里住过吗？我住过一点。是的，但时间很短，不过我希望在那里退休。那是我的快乐源泉。
It's a magical place, too. And it's the center of the universe. I mean, let's be honest. New York City, everything you need is there. Yeah, it's true. It's such an amazing town. It really is. All right. Question number four, what do you like to do on the weekends? I love to putter around at home. I'm not that exciting. I love my animals. You know, I've got seven rescue. You cats. Seven. Yeah. What are their names?
这也是一个神奇的地方。而且它是宇宙的中心。我的意思是，说实话。纽约市，你需要的一切都在那里。是的，这是真的。这是一个了不起的城镇。真的。好吧。第四个问题，你周末喜欢做什么？我喜欢在家瞎忙活。我没那么刺激。我爱我的动物们。你知道的，我有七只救助猫。七只。是的。它们叫什么名字？
Butters is the most dominant. He has to be kept away from the other six. He's very, very featured on your Instagram. He's very, and he demands it. He is the host. What color is he? He is buttery colored. Okay.
巴特斯（Butters）是最霸道的。必须把它和另外六只隔离开。它的照片在你的Instagram上非常非常多。它非常，而且它要求这么做。它才是主人。它是什么颜色的？它是黄油色的。好吧。
And when you come over for skating, he will command your attention and you will need to compliment him because he expects it. Okay. I got three Siamese, a mom and two of them. her babies, so that's mocha, cotton, and gerber. Are they talkative? Not really. Oh.
当你过去滑冰时，它会命令你关注它，你得赞美它，因为它就指望这个。好吧。我有三只暹罗猫，一个妈妈和其中两只宝宝，所以是摩卡（Mocha）、棉花（Cotton）和葛伯（Gerber）。它们很爱叫吗？其实没有。哦。
Not really. I've always shied away from Siamese because I thought they were very vocal. They are. Mine are not. Okay. So I don't know what that's about, or maybe they only talk when I'm not there. Okay. My aunt had a really chatty Siamese.
并没有。我一直对暹罗猫敬而远之，因为我以为它们很爱叫。它们确实是。我的不叫。好吧。所以我不知道是怎么回事，或者也许它们只在我不在的时候叫。好吧。我姑姑有一只非常唠叨的暹罗猫。
Oh. She named Nusense. And she'd be like, nuisance, stop it. That's the greatest name for a kitty. I know. Oh, man. Nonsense. Nonsense.
哦。她给它取名叫“讨厌鬼”（Nuisance）。她会说，讨厌鬼，住手。这给小猫取的名字太棒了。我知道。哦，天哪。胡说八道。胡说八道（Nonsense）。
We have a tripod named Wabi-Sobby. We have a fat, fat ginger named Obi-Wan. He was found strolling the streets of Hollywood as a kitten. Someone gave it to me. And, oh, Little Jacks. We have a little tiger boy was the runt of the litter. Aw. Jacks.
我们有一只三条腿的猫叫“侘寂”（Wabi-Sobby）。我们有一只大胖橘猫叫“欧比旺”（Obi-Wan）。它还是小猫的时候被发现在好莱坞街头闲逛。有人把它送给了我。哦，还有小杰克斯（Little Jacks）。我们有一只小虎斑男孩，是那一窝里最小最瘦的。啊。杰克斯。
I think that's all of them. Yeah. So, yeah, I love just puttering. I like sewing. I'm really getting into sewing more. What do you sew? Clothes. You make clothes? My dream is to sew something that I wear on the red carpet and say. I want this dream to come true. Yeah. I want to make a show about it. I hope that you will. I want there to be a Rachel Ray. And then you say, who are you wearing? And you say me. Me. I'm wearing me. Thank you. Okay. You're going to be on this show. I'm on it. Yeah. Bring me on.
我想这就是全部了。所以，是的，我喜欢瞎忙活。我喜欢缝纫。我真的很想更多地涉足缝纫。你缝什么？衣服。你做衣服？我的梦想是缝制一件穿在红毯上并说出这句话的衣服。我希望这个梦想成真。是的。我想做一个关于这个的节目。我希望你会。我希望有一个雷切尔·雷（Rachel Ray）。然后你问，你穿的是谁的？然后你说我。我。我穿的是我自己的。谢谢。好吧。你要上这个节目。我上了。是的。带上我吧。
I think because getting dressed for special events is a big pain in the ass. Yes. Right? So why shouldn't we know how to sew our own stuff? I'm sorry. My mom used to sew all my formal gowns and I always had the best gowns. My mom would sew all of our like Easter outfits and she sewed for so long. She will still, she still makes stuff all the time.
我想因为为特殊活动挑选衣服是一件极其麻烦的事。是的。对吧？那我们为什么不学会自己缝衣服呢？抱歉。我妈妈过去常给我做所有的礼服，我总是穿着最好的礼服。我妈妈会缝制我们所有的复活节服装，而且她缝了很久。她现在仍然，她总是还在做东西。
Like I'm constantly bringing like pot holders and things over to Jenna's that my mom was like, I had extra fabric. Here's a pot holder. Oh, that's so sweet. That's such a mom thing to do. It really is. I always feel bad, though. My sisters and I don't sew, and we're like, one of us needs to carry on this tradition
就像我经常把锅垫之类带到珍娜家，我妈妈会说，我有多余的面料。给你一个锅垫。哦，太甜了。这太有妈妈的作风了。确实如此。不过我总是觉得很内疚。我和我的姐姐们都不会缝纫，我们会想，我们中总得有人把这个传统传承下去
where this needs to learn how to do it. It's so meditative. Really? I love cutting patterns. And I've learned how to drape on a mannequin and stuff. That's huge. But I need to, it's like I do things in fits and starts, so I need to, like, really devote some time to it. But, you know, I watch a lot of TikTok.
或者得有人学会怎么做。这太有冥想感了。真的吗？我喜欢剪裁纸样。而且我已经学会了如何在模特身上立体裁剪之类的。这很了不起。但我需要，这就像我做事总是三分钟热度，所以我需要，真的投入一些时间。但是，你知道的，我看了很多TikTok。
So I think, oh, now I'm a do-it-yourselfer. So I make a lot of messes or I start a lot of projects that never get finished. That's the show I want to watch is the DIY people that start like, I have an IKEA hack. I'm going to make a library in my foyer. And I have all this crown molding. And then they're just like, fuck it. And they bail halfway through. That would be me.
所以我以为，哦，现在我是一个DIY达人了。所以我搞砸了很多事情，或者我开始了很多永远无法完成的项目。我想看的就是这种节目，那些DIY的人开始时说，我有一个宜家改造妙招。我要在门厅里做一个图书馆。我有所有的顶角线。然后他们就，去他的吧。然后半途而废。那绝对是我。
That is absolutely me. That's the house of it. A half-built library. Oh, God. All our clutter and shit stuffed in it. St. Dennis Medical, season two up front. Can your outfit be ready? Oh, challenge.
那绝对是我。这就是它的家。一个建了一半的图书馆。哦，天哪。塞满了我们所有的杂物和烂摊子。《圣丹尼斯医疗》第二季蓄势待发。你的服装能准备好吗？哦，挑战。
Challenge accepted. Challenge accepted. Let me see what I can do. Maybe TCA's. That's later in the year, so you have a little more time. I'll do it. Yes. I'm going to do it.
接受挑战。接受挑战。让我看看我能做些什么。也许是TCA（电视评论家协会）的活动。那是在今年晚些时候，所以你还有点时间。我会做的。是的。我一定要做。
Okay. Jenna is a motivator. I'm so going to do it. She's a motivator. She'll give you a date and you're like, all right. TCA's. That I can make happen. Oh, that's exciting. Yeah. All right. I'm doing it. We're going to feature this outfit on office ladies. You sure will. That's all right. Sure, it'll be taped together. No one's going to see that tape. No, they're not. Put it in the back. All right. Number five. This is the final question. Final question. Do you have a favorite midnight snack? No, because I don't eat after like seven.
好吧。珍娜是个积极的推动者。我真的会做的。她是个推动者。她会给你一个日期，然后你会想，好吧。TCA活动。那个我能搞定。哦，这太令人兴奋了。是的。好吧。我这就做。我们要把这套衣服作为《办公室淑女》的亮点展示。你当然会的。没关系。当然，它会用胶带粘在一起。没人会看到那些胶带的。不，他们不会。把它藏在后面。好吧。第五个问题。这是最后一个问题。最后一个问题。你有什么最喜欢的深夜零食吗？没有，因为我差不多七点以后就不吃东西了。
That's very good for your body. But I do have a midnight drink, which is very silly. I'm not a good sleeper. I'm a terrible insomniac, so my sleep, I have to, like, really be regimented about it. But there's this magnesium drink, this berry-flavored magnesium drink that is delicious. And it makes you feel like hot butter melting in a pan. Oh. You just, like, drift off.
这对你的身体非常有益。但我确实有一款深夜饮料，非常傻。我不是个好睡眠者。我是一个严重的失眠症患者，所以我的睡眠，我必须，真的非常有规律。但有这样一款镁饮料，这种浆果味的镁饮料非常美味。它会让你感觉像热黄油在锅里融化一样。哦。你就会，像是飘然入睡。
And it's called True. T-R-U. I've heard of this down, lady. I also struggle with sleep. Oh. And there's always the debate, magnesium or... What's the other thing? Pot?
它叫True。T-R-U。我听说过这个，女士。我也饱受睡眠困扰。哦。总是会有这种争论，镁还是……另一个是什么？软糖？
Gummies? Yeah. Melatonin. Yes. Melatonin takes too long. It's got to build up in your system. Okay, but this magnesium drink... It's game-changing.
软糖？是的。褪黑素。是的。褪黑素起效太慢了。它必须在你的体内积累。好吧，但是这个镁饮料……它能改变游戏规则。
It really... It really is. You've got to take it like an hour before you're ready to go to bed. Lady, I wrote it down for you. Thank you. Thank you. Yeah. There you have it.
它真的……真的能。你得在准备睡觉前大约一个小时喝。女士，我为你记下来了。谢谢。谢谢。是的。就是这样。
You're welcome. We're going to... We're going to... Otherwise, what are you going to do? Stay up at night worrying? No. Thinking about all the things you shouldn't have said during the day. That's what I do.
不客气。我们要……我们要……不然你还能怎么办？大晚上躺着焦虑吗？不。想着白天所有不该说的话。我就是这么干的。
This is you, Jenna. I know. We're the same. You've got to just... We're the same. melt into the sheets. Now, will this keep you asleep all night as well? Keep you awake.
这就是你，珍娜。我知道。我们是一样的。你只需要……我们是一样的。融化在床单里。那么，这个能让你整晚都睡着吗？保持清醒。
No, keep you asleep. Yeah, you want to be asleep. Will this, will this magnesium drink keep you asleep all night? Because one of my problems is like, oh, sure, I'll fall asleep. But in three hours, you're going to wake up. I'm going to wake up from a hot flash. Oh. Then it's a whole, we start the whole game.
不，让你睡着。是的，你想要睡着。这个，这个镁饮料能让你整晚都睡着吗？因为我的问题之一是，哦，当然，我会睡着。但在三个小时后，你就会醒来。我会因为潮热而醒来。哦。然后又是一整套，我们开始整个游戏。
I will say. Yeah. I would guarantee you're going to get at least four good hours. Okay. Okay. Yeah. That's not that... Hot flashes are its own devil, you know?
我得说。是的。我敢保证你至少能睡上四个好觉。好吧。好吧。是的。那倒也不是……潮热本身就是一种折磨，你知道的？
Do you turn the air on? So I sleep with a fan blowing on my side of the bed. Okay. It's this big stand-up fan. Okay. We need to put a piece of glow tape on it because... Oh. I need it positioned, like, really kind of right in front of the bed, but it's also right in the walkway to the bathroom.
你开空调吗？所以我睡觉时床边会开着电风扇。好吧。这是一个很大的立式电风扇。好吧。我们需要在上面贴一块夜光胶带，因为……哦。我需要把它摆放得，真的很像是正对着床，但它也正好在去浴室的通道上。
Oh, so you run into it all the time. Well, I don't, but if my husband has to go to the bathroom, he runs into it. If the kids come in in the middle of the night, they run into it. So like, this is like a ridiculous. And that's going to wake you up too, isn't it? It really is. It really is. So we just, we need to, I don't know.
哦，所以你总是会撞到它。嗯，我不会，但如果我丈夫要去洗手间，他就会撞到它。如果孩子们在半夜进来，他们就会撞到它。所以这就像是一个荒谬的。那也会把你吵醒的，对吧？真的会的。真的会的。所以我们只需要，我不知道。
And at night, I'll say, hey, everybody, don't run into the fan. If you have to come in, don't remember, don't run into mom's fan. Right. And then they all just, you just hear. Oh, no. Oh, gosh, there we go. That's hilarious. Wendy, thank you so much for being on our podcast.
而且在晚上，我会说，嘿，大家，别撞到风扇。如果你必须进来，记住，别撞到妈妈的风扇。没错。然后他们全都，你只会听到。哦，不。哦，天哪，又来了。这太搞笑了。温蒂，非常感谢你来到我们的播客。
Thank you. Thank you for having me. I hope I didn't bloviate for two. You did not bloviate at all. You are just a badass. You are so funny and so smart. And we are just thrilled to just have had this time with you. You are talking about yourself.
谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我。希望我没有滔滔不绝地说个没完。你一点也没有滔滔不绝。你简直太棒了。你太有趣了，也太聪明了。我们非常高兴能有时间和您在一起。你是在说你自己吧。
You are talking about yourself. You stab it. You are the badasses. I really appreciate how vulnerable you were and talking about, like, how you've been fired. I've shared on the podcast before how I've been fired. And it's like, because I think people look at you and we see all the successes. We see 10 seasons of the Goldbergs and Reno 9-1-1, and you don't see all the, like, lows. Right.
你是在说你自己。少来这套。你们才是最棒的。我很感激你表现得如此脆弱，谈到，比如你曾经被解雇过。我在播客里也分享过我被解雇的经历。而且就像是，因为我觉得人们看着你，我们看到了所有的成功。我们看到了《戈德堡一家》和《雷诺911》的10季，而你没有看到所有的，比如低谷。没错。
And I think it's really helpful for aspiring artists to know there are ups and downs. And you just keep going and you never know, and new wonderful things will find you. And, I mean, now here, St. Dennis Medical. You know, there's like an actor's checklist. Like, you're going to get fired. Yeah. You're just going to get fired. Check it off the list.
而且我认为对于有志于此的艺术家来说，知道其中有起有落是非常有帮助的。你只需要继续前进，你永远不会知道，新的美妙事物会找到你。而且，我的意思是，现在这里，还有《圣丹尼斯医疗》。你知道的，演员有一份清单。就像，你会遭到解雇。是的。你就是会被解雇。从清单上划掉。
Someone's going to tell you you're ugly. Check it off the list. Yep, got that one. None of this stuff is true unless you think it's true. Right. But it's probably not true. Like, just get used to it, make friends with it. if you're not supposed to be somewhere, sometimes it takes something terrible to move you
有人会告诉你你很丑。从清单上划掉。是的，那个也有了。除非你认为这是真的，否则这些都不是真的。没错。但它可能不是真的。就像，习惯它，和它做朋友。如果你不应该呆在某个地方，有时需要发生一些糟糕的事情来促使你
away from it. That's just how it goes. And so then it makes you question, do I really want to keep doing this? And if the answer is yes, buck up and just keep going. And a lot of times your biggest breakthrough won't happen until something catastrophic happens. Yeah. That's like a hallmark of good things to come. So all you guys out there that are feeling like you want to do this, It's not easy, but it is very fun. Yeah. The good times are really, really good. And you appreciate them because of the journey.
离开它。事情就是这样。然后这就会让你产生质疑，我还想继续做这个吗？如果答案是肯定的，振作起来，继续前进。很多时候，你最大的突破不会发生，直到发生了一些灾难性的事情。是的。这就好比好事情即将来临的标志。所以你们所有那些觉得自己想做这件事的人，这并不容易，但它确实非常有趣。是的。美好的时光真的是非常非常美好。而且因为这段旅程，你会更加感激它们。
It's a journey. Yes. Yeah. Oh, thank you so much. Thank you for having me. Thank you. Well, everyone, that was our chat with Wendy McLeendon Covey, and I loved it. She's just so funny, like, just in person, just like how she talks and her stories and
这是一段旅程。是的。是的。哦，非常感谢。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢。好了，各位，这就是我们与温蒂·麦克伦登·科维的谈话，我太喜欢了。她太有趣了，就像，单凭她说话的方式和她的故事
Anyway, wow, what a treat. And of course, Angela is going to share all the links to all the things that we talked about, and you have to check out St. Dennis Medical. It is a phenomenal cast, a great show, and we are so excited for season two. All right, everyone, thank you for writing in your questions, and we will see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
无论如何，哇，这真是一场视听盛宴。当然，安吉拉会分享我们所谈论的所有事情的所有链接，你们一定要去看看《圣丹尼斯医疗》。这是一部演员阵容豪华、非常棒的剧集，我们对第二季感到无比兴奋。好了，各位，谢谢你们写信提问，我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听“办公室淑女”。《办公室淑女》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室淑女》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。